every good cook should know how to roast
a chicken it's an essential skill but to
a lot of people it can seem really
intimidating so we did the dirty work
and spent weeks testing roasting and
carving and we found the juiciest
crispiest most foolproof roast chicken
recipe you'll ever need
before we get cooking we need to talk
chickens specifically how to buy the
right chicken the most important thing
to consider is size how many pounds per
person do you really need a good rule of
thumb is that for every one person you
need about a half pound of chicken we'd
also recommend getting an air chill
chicken rather than a water chilled one
while air chill chickens are more
expensive they aren't packed with extra
water allowing them to cook more evenly
and to stay more moist
once you have your chicken it's time to
get it prepped but before we do you
don't need to wash your chicken this
won't rinse away any of the bacteria you
actually run the risk of contaminating
other parts of your kitchen
so let's get down to business the number
one key to a crispy chicken is getting
it as dry as possible using a paper
towel blot the chicken on all sides
including the cavity until there's no
more visible moisture left
any excess moisture will prevent the
chicken from getting that crispy crackly
skin once the chicken is dried
generously season the outside including
the underside with kosher salt and
freshly ground black pepper
a lot of recipes use herbs and spices to
season their chickens like rosemary
thyme and sage but for our recipe we're
keeping it simple salt and pepper is all
you need
so this next bit may seem a bit
unorthodox take any pointy implement we
used a toothpick and poke 20 or so holes
all over the chicken including the legs
the exact number doesn't really matter
just make sure you cover every bit of
the surface this method lets excess
moisture out guaranteeing you crisp skin
once you're done transfer to a rimmed
baking dish and let the chicken rest in
the fridge for at least eight hours to
really let the salt work its magic
this is called a dry brine salt isn't
just for seasoning this will draw even
more moisture from the chicken
tenderizing the meat and really upping
the skin's crisp factor we also tried
wet brining our bird and while the
flavor was great the skin didn't get as
crispy as our dry brine despite it
taking even more work we also tested
stuffing the cavity with vegetables and
aromatics but they added excess moisture
while roasting which prevented the
chicken from getting crispy
just before you're ready to take it out
preheat your oven to 450 degrees once
you take it out of the fridge let the
chicken rest for an hour at room
temperature like you would any other
meat just before it's time to pop the
chicken in the oven we're going to tie
it up or truss it trusting your chicken
will result in a more evenly cooked bird
take a piece of butcher's twine we'd
recommend a piece about three feet long
loop the twine around the legs pulling
them together then slip each piece of
twine under its respective leg pull the
twine up to the top of the chicken then
flip the whole bird over pull the twine
under the wings looping it around the
neck and then tie it off cutting away
any excess twine
finally flip the bird back over and tuck
the wings under the breasts and there
you go you're a trussing expert
now a rack is the ideal way to roast a
chicken it raises the bird from the base
of the pan allowing excess juices to run
off and lets the heat fully circulate
around the chicken once again ensuring
an even cook
some people prefer roasting their
chicken with the breasts down when we
tested this the meat was super juicy but
the skin was soggy wear roasting hours
breast side up it gives you that classic
roast chicken look and you'll have
succulent meat and great skin if you
don't have a rack don't worry cover a
tray with whichever hearty vegetables
you want these will act just like the
rack elevating the chicken from the
surface of the tray plus they'll soak up
all the flavorful juices and make a
really good side dish now you're finally
ready to roast your chicken i know 450
seems high because the bird is dry
brined the meat is going to be
exceptionally juicy the skin is going to
be perfectly crispy however the right
way to determine its doneness is by
taking the temperature stick a meat
thermometer into the thickest part of
the chicken once it reads 165 you're
good to go once your chicken is done let
it rest for at least 20 minutes to be
thorough we tested roasting the chicken
at a slightly lower temperature for a
longer time and while still good we
found the lower heat didn't allow the
skin to get as crispy and the meat
started to get dried out
and that's it you've roasted to chicken
and it's ready to serve now we're going
to walk you through how to carve a
chicken
it takes some practice but it's a really
useful skill but first a quick anatomy
lesson there's the keel bone down the
middle the breasts drumsticks and wings
to start clip the twine from the legs
and remove it from the whole bird
to carve off the leg cut between it and
the breast another good indicator of the
chicken's doneness is if the juices run
clear from the cut when you reach the
joint bend it back and cut right through
to remove the wings simply twist them
right off
finally to remove the breasts cut down
along the keel bone slice in as closely
to the bone as you can
then angling your knife outwards remove
the breast
so you'll have the breast wing and leg
which can be further broken down into a
thigh and drumstick if you want
quick pro tip if you flip the chicken
over there are two very flavorful small
pieces of meat on the bottom called the
oysters you can use your hands to simply
pull them out
save these flavorful bits for yourself
they're a chef's treat
and there you have it you're now a
chicken roasting pro impress your
friends impress your family or even
impress yourself
making a roast chicken is neither hard
nor complicated it just takes time and
patience if you follow our steps we can
guarantee this will be the only roast
chicken recipe you'll ever want to make
okay we've got one more tip if you want
to reduce waste and get the most out of
your chicken don't throw out all the
leftover pieces add your leftover
chicken to a large pot along with onion
celery carrots garlic and any other
aromatics you want and then cover it
with water
bring it to a boil over high heat
and then reduce it to simmer for about
eight hours skimming the fat off as you
need you'll have homemade chicken stock
which you can use in so many recipes
so matt said that stock is like bird tea
basically i mean he's not wrong
it kind of makes sense
that's amazing it's kind of weird to
imagine though it makes you rethink
chicken stock
bird tea sounds so gross like beef stock
is just cow tea
fish stock is fish tea